[Music]
on this sunday night
a manitoba community in mourning shock
and heartbreak after two teens are
killed by a devastating tornado
that arrived with little warning picking
a vp
who shares his values democratic
presidential nominee joe biden weighs
his options ahead of a critical campaign
decision
a failing grade parents in quebec slam
the province's reopening plan for
schools as its top
doc warns of a second wave of covid19
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple good evening and thank you
for joining us a small town in western
manitoba
is in mourning tonight a young couple
high school sweethearts had their lives
cut short on friday night
when their vehicle became caught in a
tornado veteran storm chasers say they'd
never seen anything like it
joe scarpelli has our top story tonight
dad had to tell me
actually about it i was sleeping he had
to wake me up and i started crying
eusean campbell says he saw shayna
berneski and carter tilbury just an
hour before they were killed the 18 year
olds were driving in southwestern
manitoba friday night
when police say they were caught by a
devastating tornado
they would always come in get their
stuff always say hi to me as soon as
they walk in the door with a smile on my
face like
they're just always a good time seeing
them police say the powerful storm
tossed burnesky and tilbury from their
truck and carried the vehicle about a
kilometer in the air
can't imagine what the family is going
through
i think it's just terrible reg oral is
the manager of the grocery store in
melitta where berneski once worked
he says he's short three staff members
on sunday after they requested to stay
home and grieve the loss of their friend
she's a great great kid funny energetic
i did what she was told to do all the
time and found things to do
herself tilbury was employed at this
farm equipment dealership
his work anniversary just days away the
manager
broke down when we spoke to him seeing
the teen had a passion for volleyball
loved his truck and anything with an
engine he graduated from high school
last year
berneski just this spring it's
it's not a really good time for the town
i can tell you that right now
bill holden is the mayor of the town of
just a thousand
where everyone knows everyone it's bad
enough when you lose
two you know young people like this
anywhere but when you lose a couple of
people like this in a small community
everybody impacted
to give you an idea of how small this
town is we spoke to dozens of people and
didn't find
anyone who wasn't connected to either of
the teens or their families
one question many are asking is what
they were doing the night of the tornado
and why joel scarpelli global news
environment canada measures the
intensity of a tornado on a scale
between 1 and 5 with 5 being the most
powerful
this tornado had an ef2 classification
producing winds around 190 kilometers
per hour
one storm chaser who witnessed the
twister says he's never seen
anything like it it was uh one of the
most
surreal things i've ever seen in my life
i've seen a lot of tornadoes
and most of the time the tornadoes
aren't you know aren't as big and they
aren't just photogenic
oh my gosh aaron jay jack watched the
twister
tear across a farm damaging buildings
equipment and vehicles
he understands why the tornado might
have caught residents in the area
by surprise where the tornado was
happening there wasn't any rain it was
sunny
so i think most people didn't really
realize that it was a situation that
potentially produced a tornado at that
moment environment canada issued a storm
warning at 6 30
pm at 7 43 that was upgraded to a severe
thunderstorm warning
the tornado warning wasn't issued until
7 49
only about 10 minutes before the twister
touched down
environment canada says spotting a
tornado via satellite can be difficult
and it relies heavily on reports from
the ground
turning now to beirut thousands of
protesters took to the streets again
today demanding justice and change
lebanon's government was already
struggling to deal with a deep economic
crisis when a warehouse filled with
ammonium nitrate exploded on tuesday
that blast killed more than 150 people
and left
thousands of others injured as mike
delay explains the explosion may be a
tipping point
for the country
the cleanup is underway in beirut from
one of the worst explosions in human
history
and from the riots that threaten to
engulf the city i'm not
against you know protest i'm with it but
i'm against any violent protest
because it will not do what we want what
they're demanding
is a new government and in a country so
divided along religious and political
lines
this is one issue where the majority
appear to agree
and considering lebanon's recent history
with revolution in civil war
world leaders are concerned that
desperation could lead to conflict
last week french president emmanuel
macron toured the blast site
and on a virtual donor conference with
other world leaders this weekend
put all his fears on the table
the future of lebanon is at stake he
says the future of the lebanese people
but also the whole region actually
you're gonna have a huge humanitarian
crisis that like
we're talking uh syria potentially more
in terms of
uh people fleeing uh the country right
because there's nothing left
and on that line you're gonna see a huge
political potentially uh violent
um repercussion as well so so the next
few days are going to be very telling on
which path
lebanon is going to go in the first
domino has already fallen with the
minister of information stepping down
apologizing for failing the lebanese
people five lebanese lawmakers have
already quit in protest
now all eyes are on the government to
call a new election amidst the
humanitarian
and political crisis lebanon is at a
tipping point
which way will it fall microlight global
news toronto
well to politics south of the border now
where suspense is building over who the
presumptive democratic presidential
nominee joe biden will choose to be his
running mate
biden has committed to picking a woman
and several names are still in
contention
if elected biden would be the oldest
sitting president in u.s history
so his choice for second in command is
garnering a lot of attention
jennifer johnson reports joe biden
relaxing on the delaware shore
but behind the scenes the presumptive
democratic presidential nominee
is expected to make a critical decision
this week choosing his running mate
welcome mr vice president a new name is
in the mix michigan governor gretchen
whitmer
who biden met for several hours last
weekend you've got a nominee who's
trying to
vet a running mate as carefully as
possible to make sure that there are no
surprises
and at the same time you've got a
nominee who wants to
make an announcement that catches
everyone by surprise
during the democratic campaign biden
pledged to put a woman on the ticket
making his vp selection one of the most
important in u.s history
i commit that i will in fact appoint a
pick
a woman to be vice president other big
names in the running
probably no more than i do senators
kamala harris
elizabeth warren and tammy duckworth an
iraq war veteran
congresswoman val demings a former
orlando police chief
and former national security adviser
susan rice i can't talk about
the process as it stands i want to
respect the vice president
and his ability to pick the the person
that he deems best
republicans have hammered rice over the
2012 benghazi attack
which left four americans dead and are
multi-million dollar investments
you're out of order harris has been
criticized for being too tough
some experts denounce the double
standards they're too ambitious
they are too engaged in national
politics they are too willing to attack
and my personal favorite they have a
propensity for cursing
since when have any of those attributes
ever been held against male candidates
biden's wife is standing by her guy
whoever he chooses
it's got to be joe's decision who he
feels
most comfortable with who shares his
values jill biden says she wants her
husband to have the same strong
relationship with his vice president
as biden had with president barack obama
whoever he chooses
if elected she will be america's first
female vice president
jennifer johnson global news washington
and the u.s has now crossed another
troubling milestone in the covit 19
pandemic
according to johns hopkins university
the country has now topped more than 5
million cases that's about a quarter of
all confirmed infections worldwide since
the pandemic began
just five states florida texas
california new york and georgia
account for 40 percent of the country's
caseload
the u.s has also recorded by far the
most deaths
with more than 162 thousand
and this was the scene in rio de janeiro
today as brazil marked its own grim
record more than 100 000 brazilians have
died from covid19
the second highest death toll after the
u.s a memorial on copacabana beach
marked the deaths with a hundred crosses
planted in the sand
and one thousand biodegradable balloons
released into the sky
brazil also has the second highest
number of cases overall
with more than three million people
testing positive
and following the us and brazil india
has the third worst outbreak in the
world
more than two million people have tested
positive there and more than forty three
thousand have died adding to that tragic
toll
a fire today at a facility for covid 19
patients
claimed several lives at least 11 people
died when the early morning blaze broke
out at a hotel that was being used to
house patients
in the southern part of the country 22
others were taken to hospital
it's believed an electrical short
circuit sparked the fire
this is actually the second deadly fire
at a covet 19 facility in india
in less than a week and more grim news
out of india tonight
the death toll from a massive landslide
has risen to 43.
rescue crews recovered more than a dozen
bodies today
they're scouring the debris hoping to
find survivors
nearly two dozen people are still
missing the landslide triggered by heavy
rains
happened while many workers at a tea
plantation were sleeping
more rain is expected in the region this
week
and on the island of mauritius locals
are scrambling to contain an ecological
disaster
volunteers on the small nation are
rallying to clean up tons of fuel
now leaking from an oil tanker stranded
off the coast
some are even making barriers of straw
to try and absorb the oil
about a thousand tons has leaked from
the japanese vessel which ran aground
last month mauritius is known for its
world-renowned
coral reefs and environmentalists say
thousands of local species
are now at risk nagasaki is calling on
the rest of the world to join a movement
to ban
nuclear weapons exactly 75 years since
the japanese city was destroyed by an
atomic bomb
[Music]
bells rang out at 1102 local time this
morning the very moment the u.s
dropped an atomic bomb on the port city
triggering japan's surrender and an end
to the second world war
that bomb exploded with a force
equivalent to 22
000 tons of tnt an even more powerful
weapon than the bomb dropped on the city
of hiroshima three days earlier the
blast killed tens of thousands of
japanese civilians and injured
many thousands more nagasaki's mayor
heralded the survivors for their efforts
to raise awareness about the pain
and horrors they'd endured to date 44
countries have ratified the treaty on
the prohibition of nuclear weapons
japan is not one of them and neither is
canada
still ahead quebec prepares to update
its back to school strategy
as a growing petition of parents demand
support for remote
learning and
asymptomatic spread a new study shows
how those without symptoms can
unknowingly transmit covid19
people in southern ontario are flocking
to local beaches in an attempt to beat
the heat temperatures are expected to be
in the low 30s but with humidity will
feel more like 40 degrees celsius
ontarians won't see any relief anytime
soon environment canada expects that
heat to stick around until at least
tomorrow but could persist
into tuesday for the first time in
months ontario has now recorded fewer
than a hundred new cases of kovit 19
for seven straight days today the
province announced 79 new
cases the bulk of them in toronto
ontario has recorded more than 40
000 covet 19 cases since the pandemic
began
two new deaths were also announced today
bringing the provincial death toll to
just
over 2 700. and health officials in
quebec are now warning that province is
on the cusp of a second
wave of covid19 as the province prepares
for a potential influx of new cases
plans are also moving forward to get
students back to school
as gloria henrique reports some
concerned parents are now threatening
legal action against the government
robert panetta is preparing his daughter
to head back to school
but the family's usual excitement has
been replaced by uncertainty
the obvious what's going to happen if
her pod is sent
into isolation what would happen if a
second wave comes in panetta's fears
come as public health officials are
warning a second wave is on its way
we are at a critical point in our fight
against cleveland 19
on the cusp of a likely second wave of
cases that could arrive
as early as in fall the province's back
to school plan means
students from preschool to grade nine
will go back to class full time
it doesn't offer the option of online
learning without students having to
leave school
parents say it doesn't include a
contingency plan and that second wave
hits
a new petition demanding change has
garnered more than
17 000 signatures concerned parents want
the government to accommodate families
that can't take the health risk of
sending kids back to physical classes
it is not for the state to interfere and
tell parents
whether they feel safe in quebec masks
or face coverings are mandatory in all
indoor public spaces
but unlike in ontario and alberta
students in quebec will not be required
to wear masks in school
this weekend thousands of demonstrators
marched through downtown montreal
to protest against the province's
mandatory mass regulations
the province's education minister says
he won't comment on the matter
in high school all the kids are 12 years
old and more so are they going to be
wearing a mask if yes do we have enough
masks for them
are we going to pay for it a new back to
school plan is expected to be released
next week as for panetta he hopes it
will provide
more clarity and more peace of mind
gloria enriquez
global news montreal there remains a lot
of concern
and questions about asymptomatic spread
whether people without any symptoms of
covid19 might still be spreading the
virus
well now researchers in south korea have
published new evidence that shows that
even people who don't develop any
symptoms
do carry large amounts of the virus that
study published in the journal of the
american medical association
analyzed samples from symptomatic and
110 asymptomatic people
and it found that both groups had
similar levels of viral load in their
lungs
noses and throats throughout the entire
course of infection
experts say it strongly suggests that
people without any symptoms can
unwittingly spread the virus
it also found that asymptomatic people
became virus free
around day 17 compared to day 19
or 20 for those with symptoms that's
longer than the quarantine period
required in most countries
including canada
still ahead how a skateboard squad is
rallying nova scotia's girls
to get on a roll
welcome back in nova scotia a growing
number of women and girls
are rolling into a new sport an
all-girls skate crew is now leading a
skateboarding tour for women throughout
the province this weekend
it's all part of a wider effort to
encourage women on wheels
to take on a sport traditionally
dominated by men
alexa mclean has more
i've got it i'm poppy george i'm 10
years old and we're at halifax skate
park right now
when poppy was first introduced to
skateboarding by her father
she had no idea she would be joining the
ranks
of a fast-growing movement of girls and
women in nova scotia
getting involved in this traditionally
male-dominated sport
we do this for girls to encourage girls
but we want to include
everyone that's transgender non-binary
all the guys we love the guys like we
love everyone we just want to see
everyone get together and have a really
good time
and give girls the motivation to come
out and actually try this sport they
might be
too intimidated to do otherwise katie
mott is a founding member of a
grassroots group
called skate in the slow lane
a self-proclaimed girl skate crew
originating on the south shore of the
province
during the early days of the pandemic
the crew gained a lot of online
attention through videos they posted now
that restrictions have loosened the
crews are leading a tour
throughout different skate parks in the
province with covet protocols in place
it's super motivating constant progress
everyone just feeds off each other's
energy
it's not a competition at all for poppy
having these young women as role models
helps foster her sense
of self confidence be yourself and do
what you want to do
and it's just super exciting to know
that i'm not the only girl who
skateboards
the crew is now focused on growing the
community by empowering girls and women
to take on the sport
hoping that growth will help everyone
through an unprecedented time
people are a lot more accepting than
you'd think if you just go out there
with a good attitude
and try things and we are always always
always into having new people show up
and skate with us
alexa mclean global news halifax and
that is global national for this sunday
i'm jeff semple tonight your canada
is this lovely shot of a crab fishing
boat being welcomed home to cartwright
on the coast of labrador
thanks for watching have a great night
you